[Music]
you're a foot locker employee you've
been accused of a crime stealing shoes
no
filling in the white parts of your shirt
that's a good that would be that would
be a devastating crime yeah you're
getting fired from that [ __ ] god
you get that's a cardinal sin bro like a
solid black polo now yeah you're you're
not supposed to violate a right you
hooked up with a girl from champs
you were bartering with people that
lived do those food locker guys have
whistles
they do have whistles
i never see them use it they all have
well i think they'll be obnoxious as
[ __ ]
shoe size they could blow it everyone go
blows that's where it is
you failed to sell the shoe cleaner with
the shoe combo oh yeah
that makes sense you cannot do that if
you don't [ __ ] upsell bro why are you
even working there yeah why are you ever
going to shoot palace bro
you said he was suspended or fired um
he was uh
taking shoes and bartering with other
people in the mall
backdoor sales oh
he was switching the counterfeits with
the reels
that's a good one what's a good one
when i used to sell drugs uh my friend
worked at foot locker and i went over
there
and um he put he
got money out of the register and he
paid me with that and as i handed him my
illegal substance i looked at him with
so much disgust and i walked away
he sounds classier than this cat okay
because i still took the money really
bad this guy's a scumbag so what this
guy did was
like pee in the shoes or something close
he would close he would have sex with
and also ejaculate into sneakers and
then put them back he would [ __ ] a shoe
why he [ __ ] the shoe
he [ __ ] both shoes how would you how
would you [ __ ] a shoe well think about
like that tie the laces real tight you
could [ __ ] one shoe you're choking the
sneakers man and that's hot right
everyone agrees that's hot but if you
could [ __ ] two shoes at the same time
that's that's everyone's fantasies
i mean it is gross if you think that
he's doing it with the kid's shoes oh
yeah he should go to jail if he's doing
the case that's disgusting i'm sorry i
just wanted to make it worse
but it is a funny image though if you
saw a dick with a sh kid shoe at the end
well it probably feels better imagine
it's la lights and it keeps blinking
every time you [ __ ] it
oh man
it's supposed to be closed yeah what the
heck hey what the heck is going on in
here he's just doing it with reebok's
pumps
there it is oh yeah those work real good
i bet damn damn you're starting to not
be mad at this guy yeah yeah it's so
weird right because if you if you have a
if you have a shoe fetish this is like
this is like a kid in a candy store
you're a [ __ ] it's a you control
himself you're constantly horny because
you're just like but aren't shoe
fetishes based off the shoes that like
your crush war
why do you know that isn't that what it
is get the [ __ ] out of here dude why
don't you know that japanese all right
bart
why did you ask that like we're all
supposed to be like know that question
you're part japanese why does jk have hr
i need to [ __ ] file a complaint i'm
the hr okay
that's the problem hr plug joe's hr
we're all followers
i think i've been sexually molested by
hr
jose hr now there's only dudes here you
gotta find an adult yeah
just tell me your complaints it's
usually toward bart don't leave your
shoes around bart dude no emails you
tell me your
complaints with c-u-n
i have a suggestion box an anonymous
suggestion box over there that i [ __ ]
sometimes every friday afternoon
you wanna know something worse than that
that i have a friend who's doing this
yeah he was 17 at the time he was in
houston i might already told you this
but he uh worked at an ice cream shop
yeah he told us oh man that's disgusting
he's in san antonio actually and he used
to he used to come in the vanilla oh
and he used to get off and watch people
eat it
oh my god
that in turn would make him come so then
the cycle of come continue so he he
would think about people eating his [ __ ]
and he gets horny was it teala milk
vanilla
it was strachanella
maybe that's why i got eczema like maybe
it really isn't the food this guy could
be one of those guys where he like just
wants to see people put the shoe on and
he's like
sick man [ __ ] sick
yeah that's a really common thing man
disgusting man i'm so glad i don't have
like weird [ __ ] like that
like i i have a simple
you know like lick my [ __ ] dick shame
just touch it that's how i touch it yeah
keep it simple dude i'm like sit on the
balloon until it pops you you can never
it's such a blessing like like licking a
dick never felt so simplified thank you
god look at that i don't do any of that
stuff i gotta eat [ __ ] or [ __ ] stick
a screwdriver in my eyes just hold my
hand and give me kisses normal [ __ ] and
just like man i don't know what it is
dude i just gotta get a [ __ ] la
[ __ ]
la gear shoe like a classic throwback
give me a reebok i need to [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of it dude i'm gonna like watch the
face of the [ __ ] salesman after i put
the shoe on yeah if there's a smile
yes
he's too excited
gotta admit though he could just love a
commission you don't know oh you don't
know what's going on a commission that
was that's joe's email mission to come
yeah i work
commission only yeah
refusing to rat everyone else
yeah like it's a [ __ ] catholic church
and there's a whole shoe [ __ ]
organization oh my god i'm gonna look at
i'm never gonna go to a foot locker
again no never see that's there you go
one of these employees they just take
them and just put another pull out
here's another conspiracy what a bottle
what if all the clothes at outlets were
just [ __ ] [ __ ] stained things that are
perfectly well
we should think about it more but we
took this guy's face i had to go outlet
shopping dude he did he bought a cool
jacket there i don't want to go over
anthony
anthony got a kendra's jacket there yeah
it's a discount for a reason let's go to
full locker and be like hey can i get a
[ __ ] size seven in those come verse
and he's like
how'd you know yeah you know what though
if it really was a 50 off deal i'd be
like give me the one would they come i
know because i could just wash it give
me the one with the [ __ ] and it's on my
foot you know it's like [ __ ] it bro yeah
like it's a it's worth it ask them hey
you got any of these but just put some
come on if it's like a rolex i'm down
hey can i have the rolex that you came
on i'll pay 50 percent yeah that's
pretty that's a good idea but like look
at look at it come on rolex is different
because sometimes they'll give you
display items they'll give you display
items for a discount right because
they're like you could just be like oh
come on man you know everyone's been put
their foot in this come on man and
they'll be like ah let me talk to my
manager okay 10 off you know i'd be like
come on you [ __ ] nutted all over this
[ __ ] didn't say how long i got caught
uh well yeah he uh unfortunately
he was the store manager he also
reported he confessed he recorded
himself doing this he recorded himself
it's the best one he also was seen in a
video
completely naked
with a shoe around his dick cording
himself oh man
[ __ ] shoes and then yeah later on in
the video he confessed to ejaculating in
the shoes and bringing them to the
storefront where customers could be
exposed
this men's whole ritual yeah i don't
know if he puts the shoe on loose and
then he grabs the shoelaces like a
ponytail i mean what would you do i mean
i guess
they're so [ __ ] bad dude i guess
that's where it went that's what i
wanted [ __ ]
chuck taylor
[Laughter]
that's exactly where i wanted this video
to go is how would we all
violate a ship yeah and with shield this
is up for all the shoe heads out there
which shoe would you [ __ ] do you told
us yeah tell us how you know [ __ ]
weirdo you [ __ ] do this
is your dick within that
he's
where's your dick where's your dick
right here
you haven't seen a dude butt ass naked
with just a [ __ ] shoe on their crotch
just spinning it
what idiot works at a place doesn't know
where his own cameras are why do you
think i picked this article guys i
wonder if this guy role plays i wonder
if this guy role plays or he puts
another shoe and go
it's not what it seems i'm so sorry no
you wanted two
okay oh
let's wait left two i thought it was
right you were right shoes what are we
gonna be wearing
with twins i thought you were left shoe
i didn't know your [ __ ] right shoe oh
my god oh my god
you know i can't tell the difference i
don't know
i'm so sorry i'm dyslexic
and horny
it would have made more sense if it was
that finish line you know
disgusting anthony i don't get it it's
disgusting [ __ ] bro
has something to do with finland
yes
finish
[Laughter]
it's not liquid that 19 mil is not
liquid
it's in planes
[Music]
you